dc's legends of tomorrow is brought to
you by Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice
Here I am
Bruce Wayne meets Clark Kent I love
bringing people together
the greatest gladiator match in the
history of the world
experience it in imax rated pg-13
hey youtubers is charlie new beatdown
footage drop last night and Zack Snyder
actually talked a little bit about some
of the extra Justice League characters
so I'm gonna do a breakdown of that
hands down two favorite moments Batman
showing up to play well I'm here let's
get it on and him driving the Batmobile
to land on this dude firing the heavy
weapons I cannot wait to see the behind
the scenes from this movie so much of it
looks like it was built on a stage like
they built a lot of these buildings
obviously them driving the Batmobile
through a building is probably going to
be part CG but a lot of this looks like
it was practical they actually built and
then destroyed a lot of these structures
the way then Affleck described his
Batman is that he just like totally
fried on the idea of superheroes given
what's happened in Gotham the last 20
years Robin died his war with the Joker
collateral damage just destroyed him
emotionally really it's the collateral
damage and I love the way they are
dressing that like a man of steel
everyone's like hey Superman's flying
through all these buildings he's just
drawing half the city well it's kind of
a Batman's doing to this warehouse in
this clip too so even though like a big
theme of the movie is collateral damage
like look you're a god you could
seriously wreck the entire planet if
you're not careful Henry Cavill said
that when the movie picks up he's so
afraid of hurting people that he allows
himself to get goaded into this fight
with Batman yeah he could shut him down
hardcore if he wanted but he doesn't
want to kill anyone in Batman is out for
blood they even posted this image from
the movie very reminiscent of Dark
Knight Returns Batman just giving
Superman the boot it in more fun stuff
most of the movie is going to revolve
around their narrative but Zack Snyder
because they're setting up all this
justice league stuff he was talking
about flash and cyborgs and a lot of the
other surrounding people that are going
to show up the only people that I'm
pretty sure are not going to show up in
the movie or green lanterns or if we do
see Green Lantern's we'll just see some
of their names the other producer said
that we probably won't see green lantern
stuff like actual Green Lantern rings
Green Lantern Corps till after Justice
League part 1 which I'm totally fine
with I mean they've already got so many
things that set up the Zack Snyder
described the flash and cyborgs stuff
going on in the movie even though it's
relatively background is really weird
and really amazing compared to the more
traditional superhero narrative with
Batman and Superman like the batman
superman stuff will look like your
typical superhero film so he's having a
little bit more fun with this other
justice league stuff so it's going to be
really exciting it'll be fun to try and
spot all the easter eggs thing which one
Easter Egg that you probably won't see
maybe there might be a reference to a
but Jenna Malone's Batgirl character got
cut out she's supposed to be playing
Barbara Gordon and she's only going to
appear in the extended cut of the film
the r-rated cut that they're releasing
later in the year right now they're
calling that the ultimate cut I don't
know how much longer it's going to be
than the normal cut of the film the
normal cut of the film that we go see in
theaters is going to be about two and a
half hours long so it's going to be like
lord of the rings extended edition only
it'll be rated R I haven't got
confirmation on it but they're
definitely releasing the rated-r DVD but
they might be screening that are cut of
the film in theaters like a limited run
in theaters but it wouldn't be till at
least four or five months after the
regular movie comes out the Star Wars
Episode seven DVD took about four months
to be released after the movie was
released in theaters so I'm guessing
we're going to see the r-rated Batman vs
Superman cut by the end of the summer
but let me know in the comments would
you be willing to pay extra money on top
of a normal movie ticket price to see a
longer cut of the film like a longer
r-rated cut normally the mantra is you
release one cut of the film in theaters
you don't want to fracture your audience
but but nowadays people are more open to
releasing longer cuts of the film on DVD
you know much later re-releasing things
in theaters that are slightly changed
thinking which I've already done a
Deadpool video for the stuff that
they're changing about the next cut of
the Deadpool movie they're releasing a
super hardcore version of that movie so
i'll post a link for it in the
description and i am working on some new
deadpool that i'll post later today it's
a new star wars the force awakens I was
going to do a narrow grave video that
might happen tomorrow but I'll try to do
a quick Facebook and Twitter version of
that arrow video so the links for
facebook are like facebook.com /
emergency awesome in my twitter link is
just like a little bit different it's
awesome emergency just because emergency
awesome is too many characters for
twitter so you guys can follow me there
while you guys wait for that new
Deadpool video to post you can click
here to learn about the stuff that Fox
banned from the first cut of the film
book theatrical cut and you can click
here to learn about the stuff that got
banned from Batman and Superman there
actually is some stuff that got banned
in international countries so thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you